لنحاول مشاهده مره اخرى الصور التي وردتنا
قبل قليل
حيث مكان اقامه والده
جاك تكسيرا الضابط
في الحرس الوطني وهذه الصور
وهذه الصور التي تتداولها الان وسائل
اعلام امريكيه لعمليه الاعتقال
تاتينا مباشره الان من ولايه
مساجا بعد راينا قبل قليل ايضا
قوات من
الشرطه قد
توجهت الى مكان اقامه والده
هذا الضابط في الحرس الوطني الجوي الذي
قام بتصوير هذه الوثائق
وفضحيها ما استدعى الان
مما استدعى والبنتاجون تقليص عمليه الشرح
وتوزيع الوثائق الاستخباراتيه
اجراء احترازي للحد من تسريبات مزيد من
التسريبات
ايضا كانت التحقيقات في هذه الاثناء تسير
لتحديد المشتبه به الذي القي القبض عليه
قبل دقائق
وبعد ان جرت تفتيش عمليه تفتيش لمنزل
والدته هذا هو يشاهده على الصوره
وهذا هو منزل الوالده في مساج
الضابطه السابق في الحرس الوطني
وهي يتم اقتياده بعد اعتقاله عمره 21 عاما
وهو ضابط في الحرس الوطني الجوي
التصويبات كانت قد انتشرت قبل حوالي شهر
ولكن
كان هناك ربما تقصير في عدم فضح هذه
القضيه لا نعرف من اين ذلك التقصير قبل
قليل شاهدنا الايجاز الصحفي المتعدده يقول
بانه قبل يوم تقريبا من انتشار هذه بعد
انتشار هذه الوثائق تم احاطت وزير الدفاع
بالقضيه
وهذا الموضوع رفض الحديث عن تفاصيله كثيرا
وقال بان التحقيق الجنائي الان من قبل
وزاره العدل يتم في هذه اللحظات هذا هو
جاك تكسيرا المشتبه بانه قام بعمليه
تسريب وثائق تابعه لوزاره الدفاع الامريكي
وهي تسريبات لمعلومات حساسه تخص انشطه
العسكريه وكثير من المعلومات العسكريه
وعلاقته وزاره الدفاع مع كثير من الدول
عسكريا مصر معنا